what is up everybody it's animak here
for
anime uproar and today i will be talking
about the very latest events
in the black clover manga including the
escanor level chadliness
of our girl mario leona and the
beginning of the final
epic showdown between the strongest
clover kingdom warriors
and the dark triad i am loving the black
clover story right now
it is absolute fire like literal fire so
let's get
into it if you enjoy our black clover
videos and you want us to keep it going
please leave a like to let me know it
really does help
and if you're new to the channel or
maybe you just haven't subscribed yet
make this the video that you subscribe
and hit that notification bell to turn
on
all notifications it's kind of annoying
but you really have to go through the
trouble of hitting that bell
and then selecting the option that says
all if you don't do that you're still
gonna miss a ton of our videos even if
you are subscribed
it's just how youtube works big shout
out to my editor dakota broski who helps
me make these videos
every week this week especially we both
had a hard job i mean both of us were
sweating
looking at that metal on a bathing scene
so you know show the man some love
link to his channel is in the
description finally this video will
contain black lover manga spoilers so
please proceed with caution
you have been warned the latest
installment of the black lover story
starts off with a flashback
before the clover kingdom mages launched
their attack on the spade kingdom
capital
noct had explained the tree of cliffhoth
ritual to the other members
of the infiltration squad the structure
of the ritual itself will actually play
a very important role
in their infiltration strategy the goal
here
is to stop the ritual and you have to
understand how the ritual works
in order to stop it the cliffhoth ritual
takes place
inside a large magic circle which
actually reminds me a lot of the
transmutation circles from fullmetal
alchemist
yami and william the sacrifices are
located in the middle of the circle
and each of the three members of the
dark triad are located at a separate
point on the outer edge
of the circle so the infiltration squad
is going to split up into three teams
and each of these teams is going to
attack one of the zograda's siblings
if the infiltrators can defeat the dark
triad before the ritual is completed
then they will automatically stop the
ritual and yami and william will be
saved
but there is also a plan b which
involves destroying the cliff off
itself using anti-magic this plan is
more dangerous because it could
potentially kill the sacrifices so yami
and william would be in danger
and yup we already know that plan a
won't work and that they will have to
turn to plan b
eventually unlike plan a plan b
specifically requires the presence of
asta
and we all know that asta is going to
play a major role in this epic fight
against the dark triad so yup
plan b is happening i mean that's just
how battle shonens work
imagine if the infiltration squad
actually managed to defeat the dark
triad
and rescue william and yami without asta
after all of that build up about liba
and asta's new devil union form
not getting to see asla in action during
this epic final showdown would be pretty
freaking
anti-climactic so you better believe
that this battle won't end before asta
shows up
and that means that asta liba and anti
magic
will have an important role to play in
this showdown
we then find ourselves back in the
present time and we see the infiltrators
pouring into the spade kingdom royal
castle
and dispatching some of the dark
disciples on their way to the magic
circle
this scene reminded me of the palace
infiltration scene from hunter hunter
although i feel that meruem and his
royal guards were even more intimidating
villains than the dark triad
but that's just my opinion meanwhile on
the outside of the castle that
giant ancient demon is still alive and
kicking
mere leona definitely gave it a powerful
punch
but that one punch just wasn't enough to
bring the monster down
however we all know mere leona and we
know that she isn't about to give up on
trying to bring the monster down
on the contrary she is actually excited
about the prospect of taking down such a
strong opponent
we then learned that mere oleona has
been training harder than
ever before following the events of the
elf saga
back when mere leona had encountered
zugred she realized that her fire magic
had no effect
on zagred's devil magic this humbling
experience motivated mario leona to get
even stronger and that is exactly what
she has been doing for the past
six months she's been getting stronger
and she's also been bathing naked
in hot lava so you know normal marijuana
stuff
at some point after yami's kidnapping
knocked went to see
merolona and man let me tell you what a
sight
it was the sizzling hot mereo leona
comes
out of the lava in her birthday suit and
knocked
looks away and tells her to put on some
clothes
dog i just lost all respect for knocked
boo
this man
okay not really that's just knocked
personality but i do feel
obligated to point out that marilona is
a smoking hot
top-tier bad ass anime waifu and if i
was knocked i would not have looked away
i can tell you that much right now
but back to the actual plot although the
plot
here was pretty great knocked came to
ask mario leona to help with the rescue
mission to save
yami and william but mera leona says
that she doesn't really care about yami
and william getting abducted
however she is fascinated by the dark
triad and their devil magic so she
agrees to take part in the infiltration
mission
and let's be real yes marilona is
excited about fighting the devils and
yes she said she doesn't care
but she definitely does care and i am
sure that she will do her very best to
help
yami and william despite her heart as
nails exterior
merliona is actually a kind and caring
person on the inside and we've seen that
from her interactions with noel and
asta merolona's encounter with zagred
taught her that despite her incredible
strength
she still has room to improve and so she
has been training to become strong
enough to defeat
devil magic throughout the entire time
skip now she finally has the opportunity
to
test her newfound power against devil
magic
and that is an offer that she is
definitely not going to pass up on
back in the present mere leona realizes
that normal fire magic attacks aren't
doing much damage to this
giant devil so she tries something new
she uses a move called
embodiment of hellfire to turn her
entire body
into mana itself merely's body becomes
the embodiment of
pure fire magic this spell reminds me of
luck's true lightning magic
keranos which is a spell that turns
luck's entire body
into a lightning bolt it seems that
mario leona has managed to unlock the
equivalent
of true fire magic except she was
apparently able to unlock it on her own
without the help of the heart kingdom
mages
and if this is what happened it actually
makes a lot of sense
mario leona is known for spending large
periods of time
out in the wilderness by herself and
since we know that the heart kingdom's
magic is all about harnessing the mana
of nature
it makes sense that marijuana would
learn to unlock the power of nature's
mana while training alone in the
wilderness
for many months on end mario leona then
goes
all out using her full power true fire
magic to absolutely
pimp smack the giant demon the giant
demon gets
absolutely bodied by menelona's attack
called
colidus brochume purgatory abyss
and the demon then drops down to the
ground as the people of the spade
kingdom are shocked that mario leona
managed to single-handedly defeat a
legendary giant
demon by the way they're only surprised
because they've never met
our smoking hot queen mero leona and yes
yes i know i am simping big time and no
i am not going to stop the chapter ends
with the three
infiltration teams arriving at their
destination
each team confronts their designated
target either vanica
xenon or dante and so the massive
final battle of this epic war arc is
about to begin
for real wow that was freaking nuts
black clover is literally on fire right
now and with the big dark triad showdown
about to begin
things are only going to get even more
intense from here and i can't wait to
see what happens
next now let me know what you guys think
how strong
and awesome is mero leona did she really
just take out that giant demon monster
on her own and if so is she going to
need to take a break now and rest
or do you think that she's going to join
in on the main fight against the dark
triad
also are you excited for the big dark
triad showdown
how do you think this long-awaited fight
is going to play out
will we be looking at three separate
fights at three separate locations or
will this eventually turn into one
epic final fight in a single location
finally how do you think
osta and liba are going to fit into this
final showdown
are the dark triad members going to
actually defeat the infiltration squad
and then osta will have to come in to
save the day or do you think that the
infiltration squad team members
will somehow overpower the zogradus
siblings
definitely share your thoughts on what
is about to happen next down in the
comments below
if you enjoyed this video and you want
to see more black lover content
right here on the channel please leave a
like to let me know it really does help
and if you're new to the channel or
maybe you just haven't subscribed yet
make this the video that you subscribe
and hit that notification bell to turn
on
all notifications you can also hit me up
on twitter
and instagram at anime uproar
i want to give a big thank you to all of
our anime uproar
patrons for making videos like this one
possible
special thank you to alpha sigma
disciple
of lord twego himself and i can't forget
all of our
the one tier patrons the ones who rise
above
all other clans including ingrata the
world acquired respect liam thompson
pate heffer
ruthean yx emperor otaku thomas jones
spidey life canal
big buddhist tungsten tarkis and denki
kaminari and finally thank you to all of
our pro hero tier patrons including the
one and only gilgamesh steelers angel
cruz anatoly kazatsky cricket xp
joe stanton very gucci jessica califon
alicia octor
bonnie parks hinokami and water their
red-haired raven florian joy and garcia
jack watches anime
fat boy games deadly saint matthew cruz
and anthony schreiber
if you enjoy our videos and you feel
that they provide value for you consider
supporting us
on patreon even a single dollar will
give you access to our patron exclusive
discord and your name will appear
in our videos along with these legendary
people
as always thank you guys so much for
watching and until next time see ya
space cowboys
[Music]
you